Katie Kirsty Je veux que tu te concentres
concentre toi concentre seconde une sorte
de traducteur certains qui induisent un
transit où as-tu eu ça
je suis une boîte comme quatre-vingts cassettes VHS que les
anciens propriétaires ont laissées au sous-sol cette
bande a comme 20 ans  quels sont vos
noms
Brian Mike nous sommes les frères
frères de la flotte tu sais c'est dans ta chambre d'
accord eh bien papa va monter et s'assurer que
tout est là
elle est là nous devons trouver plus de ces
bandes regarde cette caméra il y a
évidemment quelque chose qui se passe  ici, il y
a tous ces boutons que vous pouvez régler oh mon
dieu c'est bizarre je voyais quelque chose
et il y a cette chose que je
prends la caméra qu'est-ce que je pense que cette
caméra peut voir des choses que vous ne pouvez pas voir
où merci mon Dieu  est tellement cool que j'ai
entendu parler de la photographie spirituelle avant de
ne jamais l'avoir vue en personne
que faites-vous ici musicalement elle
parle à l'envers elle dit Bloody Mary
tout ce qui se passe est lié
au cas
Jésus n'a jamais essayé un  rien comme ça
avant comment est-elle montée si haut il
va m'emmener et si quelqu'un a
conspiré pour que nous soyons dans sa maison ce
n'est pas une coïncidence et je crois qu'elle fait
partie de la prophétie
Mike duh bouge il y a quelque chose derrière
toi tu fais